and my team Layton I think this is
possibly the second or third one we've
done and I think each time we get a
little bit better with it so do please
bear with us because we are still all
learning layer first of all remind you
of some of the domestic arrangements
please ensure that the microphones are
turned off when not in use that you do
not interrupt other speakers that if you
wish to speak point of order or pointer
decoration declare and interest or
request an adjournment you indicate this
in the chat box this should not be used
for any other purpose or conversations
during the meetin members are reminded
that they should not have alternative
communication lines open ie other Skype
chats scope of chats and that if you are
contacted by a third party during an
application you should bring this to the
legal advisors attention that if you are
attend attending the meet and to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave if a member of
the committee is contacted by a third
party during the meetin that they must
bring to the attention of the myself the
chair and as soon as possible if members
do lose connection to the meetin they
must contact the member support officer
Mandy Smith as soon as possible you all
have her number
please don't give that out over the
phone over the Layton I would like to
remind everyone present that this meetin
will be broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated theorem
the hold of the meeting will be recorded
except where there are confidential or
accept items if you make a
representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being recorded by entering
this meeting as a speaker you are also
can
bordered by the pencils and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the cancel members of the public and
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meet and when the press
and public are not lawfully excluded I'd
now like to introduce some of the people
present we have mark Russell who's sort
of strategic projects and delivery
manager
Wilo called him the tree planning
officer for today
Jack wilkinson which is a case officer
for the second one I believe it is and
Sam summers case officer idly for the
first one no jack
I'll repeat that Jack wilkinson is done
the first one and Samantha summers it's
doing the second one and in Dupre's the
plan and lawyer are you present yes good
morning chairman members everyone else
I'm indeed here yes as your legal
advisor thank you very much and Robert
Carmichael the government officer which
I often refer to as Rob or Robert so he
keeps us on the straight and narrow now
I'll move to the agenda please
you've all got them in front of you the
first item is the absence and
substitutions Rob can you do a roll call
of members present please
Thank You chair just to point out we
have received one apology from
councillor Lee Parker before we start
the roll call
yes so yes let's see if you could reply
with good morning or present councillor
suit Aires
good morning counselor Melanie Barrett
present councillor beer president
councillor David Busby present counselor
John Hinton
resin cast early jameson president
Catherine Mary McLaren present counsel
Adrienne Osborn morning prison counselor
Alison Owen counselor Steven plum
resident and we have the board members
of counselor Britton heron possibly did
speak earlier good morning Robert yes I
am here brilliant Thank You counselor
and then we also have the other board
members of council Margaret Mabry yes
good morning I'm here thank you Thank
You councillor and councillor Clive
Aarthi and councillor as he said he
might be doing some other stuff until
his item comes up patty is in the
meeting late that's all
yes Oh Thank You councillor that's
everyone chair thank you thank you very
much for that
we'll then move to item number two to
see if there's any interest is there any
to declare bony members declarations of
interest no I'm taking that as a no oh
no one's declared so we can move to the
next item then to confirm the minutes of
the meeting held on the 3rd of June they
will be following Rob did you want to
provide an answer for that
yes thank you chair I'm just to say that
a draft is not yet been completed on
those minutes and that they will be
presented to the next day the planning
committee for confirmation thank you
thank you very much so we'll deal with
them as soon as they come to one of the
next meetings
item number four to receive notification
of petitions Robert you're going do you
have any thanks
we have one petition to report today and
its associated we have the first item on
our agenda its associated application DC
20 double O 3 3 o in Boxford we have
received a petition of 96 signatures
that support the following statement we
the undersigned petition the Planning
Committee at Babbo District Council to
reject to Catesby estates application
and to build new homes on land to the
east of Sand Hill boxford that hasn't
yet been reported to Council as it was
received after the last council meeting
and we haven't held one since Thank You
chair thank you very much for that
members you'll note that that will come
up during the first application that
we're discussing there are the side
inspections so we've now moved to item
number six which is item number five
site inspections sorry
are there any called by the officers no
and none called by members know I've
taken others no thank you
so we will now move to item number six
and that is the application to be
determined by the committee and the
first one is at page 13 which is the
granting permission for land east of
Sand Hill Oxford suffered we have a case
officer Jack Wilkinson so it's over to
you
Thank You chair can everyone see the
screen perfect good morning members
members of the public I hope you and
yours are well I'm Jack Wilkinson I'm a
principal planner a medium service for
baby I'm in Suffolk
the first item as expressed is DC 20 /
zero zero three three zero is an item or
outline plan with all matters reserved
excluding access it's for 64 units and
for the provision of land for community
building so before I proceed with the
remainder of the application in terms of
the presentation I just want to refresh
the memory of members for the item that
was previously determined this was a
larger scheme for 80 units all set on
exactly the same sites in terms of the
redline outline this was refused on the
9th of October due to conflict with sis
two CS 11 and CS 15 so as you as you may
recall the site is well north of the
daily bio and be in boxford as depicted
by the red marker again the site is sat
towards the east of sand hill with the
arterial Hadley Road a 1071 running
along the South Hadley to the east
subject to the west as can be seen the
application site is shown as hatched and
pink
I will talk you through each individual
constraint in a moment as you can see
the backdrop of the boxford village a
core village
is set towards the west as a TPO tree
belt which runs along the north not in
the application site that is worth of a
note we have the special landscape area
as well which is shown in green and the
site isn't in any directly effected
constraints area so the defined red line
outline is as shown we've got the public
right-of-way which runs through the
center of the site and along the
northern boundary in terms of listed
buildings as you can see there are
several that lead off into the center
and the heart of Boxford mainly of grade
2 listed quality with also one single
grade one unit in the center and the
conservation area is outlined by the
dark outline as you can see which is a
brownish color the site isn't in a
concerning flood zone I flood zone two
or three just chosen to highlight the
public right-of-way there just to show
you where those exactly run and
obviously off of Cox Hill as well but
the extent through the site is clear in
terms of the site's relationship to the
existing built-up area boundary of the
core village this is the defined outline
shown in brown who know the conservation
area ran through here but we also have
station and field as well which is west
and indeed the northern section or
towards the east of the boxwood village
itself this is an edge of settlement
location I
6:11 is engaged whilst technically this
is in the countryside I see s2 would be
engaged c11 is in mind just to show you
some aerial views of the site it's an
agricultural field which slopes from the
east to the west as it swoops down into
the center of Boxford I've shown some
photos in a moment that that show the
topography and the contour of the land
so members you may recall the previously
refused indicative master plan which
showed the extent of 80 units this has
been reduced down to 64 units as
presented with some subtle changes as
well which I will go on to discuss one
important aspect is the orange star
which depicts a community building for
d1 use this is a welcomed benefit which
offers indoors there's also some
alteration to the attenuation Basin and
as we will go on to compare there's some
changes to the open space and indeed the
landscaping buffer towards the southern
extent it was clear and noticeable
change in this regard you may wish to
follow me with the arrow in the bottom
left-hand corner this shows where the
photo was taken from approximately and
in which direction to so this is the
slope from the western edge up towards
the crest of the hill facing southeast
this is a view from the 1871 had erode
you can see the the land sweeping down
this was taken more recently and you can
see the backdrop of station and field
which then leads into the heart of
Oxford
should we need to refer back to these
I'll be more than happy to this is
probably the best photo in terms of
showing the contour of the land the
low-lying point here where an
attenuation basin would be the backdrop
of the village which leads and narrows
off into the center this is the
permissive footpath which you can just
about see Warren
so back to the plan and as a means of
comparison I have opted to provide the
previously refused indicative plan and
show you the now proposed indicative
plan and there is reason for that there
are clear differences as I've mentioned
often members opted to refuse the
application last time out excuse me for
reasons relating sis to assess 11 and CS
15 this largely stems towards a lack of
community benefits landscaping harm and
sustainability credentials now there was
also concerned with infrastructure which
we will go on to discuss I will just
jump through and discuss what I'd like
to look at in terms of the layout and
again this is a reserved matter but it's
prudent to look at how the site could be
developed you notice there's a clear
difference in the size of the area the
attenuation Basin there would be a
benefit here whereby the existing soak
away system that serves station and
field would be incorporated as part of
this application that extent comes
through into the defined red line so
there is a benefit in that regard in
terms of flood and water we've already
touched upon this element already a d1
community building community building
would bring a wealth of social benefits
and it's certainly a good response to a
the reason for a few years were last on
but also local and national planning
quality which is what we are here to
determine on the basis of you'll see as
shown on the proposed indicative plan
the open space which is a lot much
larger error if you compare it to the
previously refused one naturally there's
less built form so there's going to be
more space to work with but again that
is a substantial benefit and again the
planting buffer which would be fixed
over a 10
long stuck through planning condition
mitigates to a degree the southern
extent there's no concern from place
services
landscape consultant and in moving to
consideration obvious is not uncommon
for the local authority to receive a
parameters plan and a parameters plan
effectively sets out the developable
area and this would be fixed amongst the
recommendation for sixty four units as
outlined so you can see the pale orange
area would be where the build form would
be sat this would provide an assurance
to members and it certainly does to
offices hence the recommendation there
will be a guarantee that the community
building would be different delivered
upon the pink area the open space in the
lighter tone of green and indeed the
planting buffer the fixed element that
is for determination today is the access
which remains unaltered from the
previous refusal and certainly that
didn't form part of the previous refusal
and leading on to that connectivity I
think it's prudent to revisit this just
to make members aware that you can step
out from sight and access the services
facilities and amenities within the core
village of Oxford members may recall the
site visit that we understood prior to
the previous application and we did walk
down from Sand Hill down the public
footpath and off into the center there
is also a public right-of-way which runs
along the north western extremity which
is accessible so there are pedestrian
options I think is prudent excuse me
I'll just move
the Skype meeting I think it's prudent
to look at what is available in in
boxford as a means of you know
day-to-day living and work in these
facilities the western edge of the
application site is towards the south
eastern corner on this image you'll know
bus stop one I'll stop to off stop three
located in the center also to school the
village hall the church the British
stores and the shops and public houses
that will inadvertently open up again
very serious we're probably well aware
there is access for residents of this
site I think it's also prudent as well
to consider the economic benefit the
spending power generated from this site
would go some way to assisting with the
prosperity of the village arguably so
that's a point that I think is
worthwhile considering the social
cohesion that comes with that will help
stimulate the village as a whole just to
delve into the final aspects of the
presentation access is secured through
the western edge onto Sand Hill your
local farmers authority raised no
objection subject to planning conditions
and indeed elements that would be fixed
through the section 106 for highway as
can be seen the red line site extent
with visibility splays both along the x
and y new proposed access the orange
marker takes the 13 mile an hour zone
right up to the a 1071 by the artillery
or bypass route where the speed limit is
40 miles an hour there would be
sufficient visibility splays in both
directions that would go above and
beyond the minimum requirements required
by the local virus Authority
I think it's worthwhile noting that
footpath provision along the site
frontage that would enable pedestrians
to link up as highlighted in yellow and
moving forward proposed footpath this is
the existing which we walked down as it
leads down into the heart of Boxford so
the Cox Hill Sand Hill Junction if you
like there's a proposal to uplift the
bus stop area and provide the footpath
along into Ellis Street as highlighted
this would be secured through the
section 106 and certainly members were
supportive of these elements last time
out the point of clarity there would be
an element of widening which is fixed on
a more accurate plan than my
illustration is just to emphasize the
idea is behind that in terms of the
footpath widening and I think that's a
healthy response members may recall the
slum Street appeal which was on the
other side of Oxford that was dismissed
by the Inspectorate on the basis of
accessibility through the paved areas
this scheme would not reflect that it
would be more than accessible I'll leave
you with some facts and figures and
again we can refer back to this should
you so need the previous refusal was on
the basis of cs2 cs3 cs4 theme on the
paragraph 38 of the MPP F LPS are
required to work proactively with agents
and the agent on behalf of the applicant
in this regard has responded well
there are stark improvements following
the previous refusal that your offices
and dorks which is captured through
planning condition and through the
section 106 this is a sustainable scheme
with good benefits and plenty of
benefits that are arising through social
cohesion harms that are identified have
been balanced very carefully by offices
in the report
comms being a landscape infrastructure
and heritage any recommendation from
members from offices sorry is therefore
for approval Thank You chair thank you
very much for that case officer Jack
Wilkinson will refer to you now as Jack
if that's okay
members are there any points you would
like clarified by the case officer no
well done then right we'll then move to
the public speakers I think we have a
question yes I servers just come up late
but it has come up councillor Jameson
can do this development would attract so
the contribution is set within the
section 106 councillor Jameson can you
get closer to your mouth we are
struggling to hear you okay much feel
he's gonna be I can try and find out
I'll come back to you on it but I know
that the development contributions of a
hundred and seven thousand five hundred
and twenty would be
settled in section 106 I will try and
get back to you on the seal and confirm
that is that okay okay
we'll get more good and get back to you
on that one yes carry on exactly is that
is gonna ensure the enhanced measures
that these promises are going to be made
what it's like condition 29 actually of
course thank you and referring back to
the previous refusal there were concerns
with regards to sustainability and the
applicant and agent have responded
pretty well in terms of that director
concern that provided a sustainability
in a pose or assessment that Jack just
among members Chancellor Jameson is
referring to page 48 and condition
number 20 million carry on Jack
Thank You Jerry so in terms of
sustainability measures the applicant
has provided a sustainability assessment
that would set out benefits that would
accrue in the overall scheme and also
the open market housing the offering is
above and beyond
building regs standard so the
sustainability credentials ie the
function and efficiency of the open
market dwellings
would be far superior to a standard per
se dwelling there would be stark
benefits that would be set out and
condition 29 is imposed to ensure that
that is captured and there would be a
guarantee that what would come forward
at reserve matters would be of a
sustainable quality in terms of the
Houngans providers hopefully that's
enough of an explanation at this point
thank you
it sounds like cancel a Jameson that
your baby to pick that up if the if we
were minded to
prove this if it came back to us with
full details any other crash also sorry
sorry chair I've just also got an answer
the sill payment conceal payment is 675
thousand pounds six hundred and seventy
five thousand right if fifteen percent
of that will be part of that big to the
parish right okay 15 percent - okay
thank you
yeah members any other questions
relating to the officers outlying Kayson
No thank you very much we'll move on
then I think your screens a bit slow mr.
chairman I've got after the question
please it's very slow all right I think
I need to widen that bit so I can see
that the bottom right councillor Hinton
Thank You mr. chairman yes sir could I
just ask the officer we're talking here
about an outlying application where
it'll come back with reserve matters
which includes the the layout but the
final layout could he's only indicative
at the moment and the community vision
of a community facility bearing in mind
the experience that was had at the new
town that they built near Cambon that
they built near Cambridge where all the
community facilities that were supposed
to be built didn't get built is there
anything that we can do in terms of s106
to secure the community space now rather
than waiting for later when of course in
theory they could start building after
the reserve matters are approved and
never actually put the community 230 in
place so it's a worthwhile point
counselor Hinton and thank you for your
question um forgive me I'm gonna revert
back to the parameters plan because this
is a fixed document that we would be
relying upon and whilst it doesn't show
the exact design and layout per se of
the site it does it does give a good
indication of what will be built where
you can clearly see the community
building shown or community land for a
community building in pink along with
the homes as discussed and the
infrastructure in terms of actual
delivery we've captured this within the
section what I've six so typically what
happens on reserve matter schemes such
as this it would be structured in a
certain way within the 106 that would
say that X home would not be occupied
until the community building is
delivered that's something that we would
structure within the section 106 so that
it is delivered in the right order we
wouldn't want to be encouraging delivery
of all of the homes and then the
community building we would want the
community building which is a focal
point which is an important point within
the early stages of the development yes
thank you mr. chairman if I could just
come back for a moment on that is there
any particular reason then why the
community building is placed close to
the existing dwellings and not further
into the site or facing threats for
instance towards the landscaping area at
the south of the site I think its
position is well-suited offices would
encourage that I mean I think you've got
to look at it in the wider context and
where it's at amongst not just the site
that's proposed but also the settlement
around it and you've got station field
directly north so arguably is sat
amongst bill form should members be
inclined to approve this scheme it would
in essence be surrounded by development
so it would sit centrally I think if you
were to ever out on a limb for one of a
better time towards the southern extent
where it's a lot Hillier and further out
from the village in terms of the actual
site I don't think that would be
beneficial I think it's Satana in a good
position and members will arrive at the
right conclusion on that I trust thank
you
any other questions of clarification
No okay thank you very much
I would now move then to the public
speakers we have Roger Luce to speak on
behalf of the parish council you sir
have three minutes in which to address
the committee and then I'll see if
there's any questions for you at the end
of it thank you good morning my name is
Roger loose I'm strongly objecting to
this application on behalf of the
Boxford parish council the proposal does
not meet the requirements of cs20 rural
exception site by virtue of its scale it
lacks adequate local needs provision and
access to village facilities is poor
members of the committee will be aware
that this application is substantially
the same as the one they previously
rejected at a village meeting attended
by over 120 residents to consider the
first case B application the vast
majority were strongly opposed to such a
development furthermore in the village
survey in February 2000 and nineteen
fifty-eight percent of respondents
thought that the village should not
expand on such a site were the committee
to agree this application it was
severely undermined the work of the
emerging neighbourhood plan the beba
core strategy five-year land suppliers
in place and the neighbourhood plan will
identify more than enough sites to meet
the village quota without the site the
development is outside the defined
built-up area in a valuable rural
setting in rolling farmland it would be
separate and isolated from the village
and totally car-dependent
given its distance from the village
centre it's inevitable the new residents
will drive into the village thereby
adding to the considerable existing
parking and congestion problems
sixty-four houses will generate at least
130 cars pedestrians will be discouraged
by the lack of safe footpath access a
new 80 metre footpath in Ellis Street
starting at the blind junction with Cox
Hill would have to be entirely on the
existing carriageway as the land beyond
the curb is privately owned and not
available
this would narrow the road to a single
lane and in addition there would be
parked cars this would add greatly to
the present danger for motorists and for
pedestrians who will have to cross the
road twice to reach the center of the
village double-decker buses and large
agricultural vehicles often towing
equipment or long trailers regularly
have to use this road through the
village and all this through the
conservation area with many listed
buildings most visits to shops school
pub Church GP surgery and village hall
will be made by car there is already
insufficient parking and the
infrastructure in this ancient historic
core cannot take anymore this is not
planning for a green sustainable future
the assertion based on Google Maps that
the majority of traffic will travel from
the pros site via the a 1071 shows no
understanding of how local people use
the roads the quickest most reliable
route to base and Edmonds the a14 in
Cambridge is north of Swan Street not
via son berik Sudbury the National
Planning inspectors decision on the
appeal for 24 houses at Goodland was
dismissed due to already existing
Highway Safety and congestion concerns
on Swan Street this scheme will add
still more traffic to that road on these
grounds the box the Parish Council asks
that you reject this application thank
you right numbers do you have any
questions for the public speaker mr.
Luce councillor Jameson thank you here
I like good morning mr. Luce community
hall I read on the objections that the
village feel the community hall is
unnecessary and not required do you your
thoughts on that mr. Luce
yes that's a strong feeling in the
village because we already have an
excellent village hall which obviously
we want to sustain as much as possible
with activity and we have a pavilion on
the playing field which is all
so used for social occasions so with two
balls already in use which we want
obviously to be as used as heavily as
possible we don't feel we want a third
one in the village Thank You councillor
Busby Thank You chair are you I think
you're in the process of putting
together a neighbourhood plan do you
have any sites allocated within that
neighborhood plan we have identified
nine sites as an inner group on the
neighborhood plan but they have not that
yet been discussed in the village or put
out the next stage is to refine that so
all I can say to you is that we have
more than enough site other than this
one to provide for the necessary quota
and therefore I take it that this one
isn't in your proposed neighbourhood
plan no this one very much isn't in our
neighbourhood plan okay thank you
Thank You councillor McCann Thank You
chair good morning mr. Luce the your
house or the Main Street in your village
sounds horrendous we've got bottleneck
gridlock insufficient parking in your
role as parish council have the parish
at the village considered what
alternative transport arrangements could
be made for the village the main
consideration over some many years by
the parish council has been where to put
the difficulty is that where there is no
land in an obvious place near the center
of the village on which you can put a
car park that's accessible safely the
the parish council is still considering
if it's possible to put a car park on
the very marshy land along Stone Street
Road but that is far from being an ideal
site because we fear that a lot of
people will not use it they will still
go on parking their cars in the village
thank you thank you thank you any other
questions
no okay counselor Hinton Thank You mr.
chairman so it come in a bit late on
that just one quick one as the local
representative mr. doose I'm sure you
can do I answer this question for me the
report talks about the bus route to
Sudbury and Hadley the service being is
at 91
how frequently is that what's the first
bus on what's the last bus it has about
six months ago it was reduced from one
and a half a litre to Ozzie the FIR
there is a morning bus and in the
evening bus back from Sudbury but it
means that you I think I don't use it
now it's it's so infrequent and lots of
my friends don't use it anymore for the
same reason which is sad but I think
there is a bus from Ipswich to Hadley
which terminates at Hadley and if you
really want to get back to boxford from
Ipswich say you need to leave before
five o'clock I believe Sudbury is is
better there's a bus that just before
half past five or something from Sudbury
back to by a boxwood but during the day
the services is useless really too early
it's far too far apart Frank Hill
there's no one else indicating they wish
to speak so I will know Frank mr. Luce
and we'll move on
we now have an objector Andrew good you
would like to speak you have three
minutes in which to address the
committee and I'll see if there's any
questions at the end of it for you son
over to you mr. good
Andrew good Rob can you help us out it
doesn't say him donkeys present alone
hello can share my computers running
extremely slowly I'll just check good is
in the meeting as far as I can tell for
he was on mute so if I unmute him mr.
good can you hear us now is that mr.
good you have three minutes in which to
address the committee after that I'll
serve as any questions for you when
you're ready it was over to you thank
you
robbed we do seem to be having problems
getting him to speak yes he's unmuted is
young can you hear me
there we are yes yes I can hear you is
that mr. Andrew good it is can you hear
me now
yes I can hear you I'll replace to the
game Suffolk time here good morning yes
my name's Andrew Goode and I'm
representing the news the Boxee society
and the neighborhood clan core group the
application is very little different for
the one your committee refused last year
there is nothing in the new application
that should change or earlier refusal I
would in fact draw your attention to the
planning policy offices objection to
this application in particular his or
her comments the box that is less
sustainable as a core village and others
that it would introduce an urban
development in a rural location it would
provide a further conflict between
vehicles and pedestrians it would be
departure from the existing development
plan it would undermine the National
Planning framework and is not an
application that he or she can support
these are the words in the report we
should give you sound policy planning
reasons to again refuse I now wish to
make reference the adjacent site at
stations field that was given approval
as an exception site itself outside the
video envelope the applicant relies on
this as the new settlement boundary
there are no exceptional circumstances
put forward by either the case officer
all the applicant as this is generally
housing not local needs with local
connections this is a matter of regret
that highways do not understand the
vehicle conflicts at the Sandhill
junction with Ellis tree even though
Sand Hill signs advised ATVs gates this
route this is a blind substandard
junction the proposed footpath would
narrow Eve even further the pinch points
in the middle of Ellis Street where
pedestrians are expected to cross many
residents have no earthly parking long
and white agricultural vehicles use
illustrate on daily basis and this
already caused a conflict between
streams and vehicles you've no means of
escape because the walls are but the
highway there is precedent through the
recent else it appealed to consider the
emerging work of the neighborhood phone
group the question their response a
local housing needs demonstrates a clear
preference for small number of sites
within the village guided by the local
crown consultation group a document the
group has already discounted at this
site it is not a site has ever been
included in the call for sites so the
application is speculative the group has
commissioned a local housing leave
survey and as appointed a planning
consultant to help deliver the objective
of sustainable development site will be
offered for public consultation that
meet that objective and is only half of
these sites were selected that would
more than meet the stated housing need
beyond the plan period I would urge the
committee not to drive the coaching
halls and through his work by granting
permission the site that bears no
relationship to the village does not
meet the criteria for policies CS
2/11/15 has not proven with tester
sustainability has no functional
relationship the village will cause
vehicle conflict in illustrate and will
required the passing out of primary
school children through 106 agreement I
will end there please please support the
35 objections from people who would be
gallery today and support the guidance
from thank you very much mr. dealers
thank you very much thank you right
there's two or three things that you've
brought up there I would just like to
ask one question and then the officer
can be looking this up while we're
taking up questions to you but you did
refer to officers less than substantial
in the report can you give a page and an
indication where this is so the officers
can look this one up and then I'll come
to them when we get into debate to give
us an answer sorry I didn't quite
understand the question you you
commented that the the officers report
stated that there was less and stench ah
yes so I haven't got the report in front
because I can't used to
screams it's the planning policy
officers objection in the body of mr.
Wilkinsons report right
okay well I'm sure mr. Wilkinson can
find that while we're going through and
I'll come to that after we've finished
questions to you okay right members have
you any questions for mr. good questions
please okay no questions to you thank
you very much mr. Goode and Jack can you
answer that particular point before we
move on I think it might be well to
clear that up
no thank you Karen I might be able to
with regards to the comments expressed
by the Planning Policy Officer this is a
this is a fine line in terms of a
Nutella page and we're both in truth
chair I can't because I don't know what
I've weaved into the report that respond
to numerous aspects expressed by
plainclothes officer I think essentially
this comes down to infrastructure the
schools and highways to you is the plan
and policy comments are expressed
forgive me let me scroll up yep they are
expressed on yeah page seven think you
seven may be wrong no no no not page
seven but in in essence the comments
expressed by the polling policy officer
all word-for-word from the consultation
process yep now it's we broke this down
last time and discussed
the Swan Street appeal we discussed CS 2
and CS 11 yep and the resultant harms
that the development would as members
saw would create we're now in a position
where we have to look at whether the
benefits outweigh the harms and vice
versa
although the harm should not be
prevalent I'm going to start with the
Swan Street appeal in terms of
accessibility now in that appeal the
inspector was clear that there would be
issues from that end of the village due
to either narrowness of the foot ways
the footpath
could you reasonably walk down them
unobstructed there was issues there with
regards to the bins cars the narrowness
and telegraph poles and it's quite a
thorough assessment in terms of access
for the pedestrian from that site into
the centre of Oxford this site is
staunchly different we walk from site
during the committee site visit last
time out and that position remains
unchallenged members should take comfort
from the fact that there would be
benefits accruing in terms of the
quality of the provision that would be
secured through the section 106 those
are nothing before offices to suggest
the accessibility clinic had extra and
from the site into the centre of Oxford
is an issue I think we have to then look
at the wider infrastructure comments and
the IDP infrastructure delivery plan
that has been produced by the planning
policy team and the offices and the plan
Policy Officer is referred to this but
we must apply appropriate weight in the
same way that we do with the emerging
joint local plan now this is a sensitive
site in terms of the accessibility but
there is nothing before offices that we
suggest that we could consider that to
be an issue given the accessibility
identified
this largely falls back into the reasons
for a fuse were last time I assist two
and CS 11 the benefits that come through
with this game are an improvement and
make you go above and beyond what
officers would require normally I won't
choose to to elaborate tomb on over
happy discussions I need yeah thank you
jack I think that's cleared at that
point members may want to question you
on that when we get into debate but
we'll move on thank you you've cleared
that point so we know where we're going
there was nothing else asked I'm now
gonna ask the applicant to speak which
is a mr. a Barrett you sir also have
three minutes in which to address the
committee the end of that house if
there's any questions for you are you
there mr. Barrett I am when you're ready
the time will start thank you Thank You
chair my name is ed Barrett allowing the
Planning Manager at Kate's this dates
the applicants following last year's
refusal of our original proposals for
the site we did not rush to appeal
instead we listen to your concerns and
have revisited our proposals to adjust
the previous reasons for refusal the
number of homes proposed has been
reduced by 20% and land for the
development of a community building is
now incorporated levels of open space
and landscaping have been increased
now comprising 55 percent of the overall
flights area to reduce impact on the
surrounding landscape the proposed
dwellings are now positioned at lower
elevations and maximum heights have been
reduced from two and a half stories to
two stories at the request of local
residents the failing drainage soakaway
serving the adjacent station field
government will be removed and
incorporated into a new sustainable
system a revised enhanced sustainability
strategy
incorporating low-carbon renewable
energy technologies such as heat pumps
and solar panels is proposed to achieve
carbon reductions of up to 42%
significantly exceeding the requirements
of the local plan
and current building regulations the
post condition number twenty nine
insures these commitments will be
delivered in light of possible
implications of the cove at 19 a
condition has also proposed requiring
homework and capabilities to be
incorporated into each home
acknowledging these amendments and
significant benefits which will be
delivered including affordable housing
delivery smaller properties for
first-time buyers and downsizes seeking
to remain in the village pedestrian
infrastructure improvements and
enhancements to the vitality of the
village the application is again
recommended for approval
I hope members agree that we have acted
upon your concerns driving us to improve
our proposals which will ensure the
delivery of a high-quality sensitively
designed development which will be
reflective of the character of the
village reflecting these significant
enhancements made to the proposals
however you can follow your officers
recommendation and vote in favor of this
application thank you thank you very
much for that mr. Barrett I have member
bhavish had asked a question
councillor Osborn your question yes sir
Thank You mr. chairman yeah I'd just
like to ask the applicant was this
brought before the parish council and
was the did you look into the the
situations and go through the
application with them please yes we did
we have a public exhibition in the
village prior to that exhibition I had
met with the parish council and
neighbourhood plan group when we were
first formulating the proposals and then
we also wrote and updated our websites
that it's been live for a time with
details of all the the revised scheme
that there's now before you thank you
was that revised scheme did that go
through - there's the same situation as
you had when when the original one was
pleased no we didn't hold on
the public consultation in the village
for the revised scheme it was done via
writing to to residents everyone in the
village was written to there was the
leaflet explaining the changes the
website was was updated and we're
available to answer questions contact
details were put on the websites that
was the arrangement right thank you very
much for that there's four people one to
question so I'll take me an order
counselor I'm an idli Barret Thank You
mr. Barret and no relation by the way I
just wondered about the comments that
were made by the parish council about
the community building had you done any
work with the village to establish what
their needs might be for a community
element to a to the scheme the parish
council had undertaken a questionnaire
as part of the preparation in the name
of the plan and the the results from the
questionnaire identified a number of
additional facilities that the residents
felt may be needed so the proposal for
the community building was responding
was responding to the results of that
questionnaire thank you very much
councillor Owen
yes my question is the same as mr.
spirits actually and just to extend on
there because d1 is all about health
health and doctors and have they any
idea what they're thinking about what
that community building will go for I
[Music]
don't quite understand what you're
asking yeah the community building is d1
so it's not like them well I at what I
understand as a d1 correct me if I'm
wrong is it will be more for her
all health places doctors nurseries have
they any idea what they would be put in
there or what that would be going for
more usages can help with that mr.
Barrett I think there's a good range of
flexibility in the d1 use class so
that's at the the reserve matter stage
further consultation with the with the
parish and local residents range
arrangement if that's all right because
two planning officers come in he may be
able to help on this one and there might
be a bit clearer of everyone thank you
yeah the applicant was halfway for
answering I want to put that so I was
aware of that but that the use across d1
is a non-residential institution if you
look at the used classes order that
lists the result of health stuff you're
correct counselor clinics health centers
crashes day nurseries day centers
schools art galleries museums libraries
halls place of worship churchill's even
a law court non-residential education
and training center so there are there's
quite a scope for uses that some of them
are health some not health I think that
helps you quite a lot to counselor Helen
okay yes thank you thank you
councillor McClaren thank you chair good
morning mr. Barrett as somebody that's
part of the demographic time bomb I just
want to make a comment that the fact
you've only got to single storey
bungalow within your application this is
a worry really because the thoughts of
people wanting to downsize and also we
have people who are less able disabled
people who are out out of work or
leading full lives would benefit from a
single storey building have you any
comment on that sure the the layouts
before you is is purely indicative and I
wouldn't read too much into it in terms
of are trying to identify particular
buildings on that at the reserve matters
stage
the detailed housing mix will be put
before you and will again come before
committee the local plan has policies
requiring a mix of properties including
bungalows so that will be an element of
the development that you would have full
control over at the detailed stage so if
there was evidence indicating a need for
more bungalows which I'm quite sure that
there possibly is in this location
that's something that would be reflected
at the reserve matter stage and there's
ample space on the site too to
incorporate that thank you thank you
Mary and I think it's a very good point
and I would just add to that that um
because you have reduced the volume of
dwellings from eighty down to 64 it
doesn't mean you have a bit more space
and I would certainly like to see
bungalows I think we all would like to
see a few more bungalows but we'll have
to wait and see when the details come
forward but just bear that in mind mr.
Barrett I'll move on because I have
another question
and that's councillor Ayers good morning
and good morning mr. Barrett and I
really appreciate all the changes that
you've made from the previous
application above and beyond and my main
question is and what some of these
houses B homes for life particularly the
bungalows with the wider doorways and
not steps how much of that will come
into your final plans because um as the
previous counts have said we've got to
think of those who are disabled others
by myself that are getting elderly so
can you help me of that please yeah
unfortunately I never have the the
definitive position on homes for life
but I certainly know that building
regulations are being updated this year
or were due to be anyway on obviously
that the houses on this site will
probably if the application was approved
wouldn't be built for a year or so so
that it's very likely that there will be
new updated building regulations which I
think are sort of replacing
homes to the life and actually take you
know increasing the the requirements for
developers so I'm certain that that the
requirements disabled and elderly people
will be incorporated okay thank you
just following on from that I have a
question to you if we were minded to
approve this how quickly would you be on
site and make a start because there has
been a concern of the committee at times
yes we would we would immediately engage
with the house builder and indeed those
are a condition requiring a shorter
period of time for submission of
reserved matters to encourage that
process to happen happen as quickly as
possible and based on our experience of
similar sites elsewhere in the country
we're normally normally seeing a period
of 12 to 18 months for commencement of
developments following the following the
the approval of outline permission so so
very quickly and then for a scheme of
this size a house builder would be
building maybe 30 30 20 per year so in
two years roughly then this this site
could be complete from from commencement
and development so you know a Larry
Swift build-out thank you
I have no one else that's indicated they
wish to ask two questions so I will
assume that you have no more questions
for mr. Barrett then members will move
on I will now ask the ward member
penciler Bryn Heron to speak you sir
Brinn have five minutes in which to
address the committee and then at the
end of that I'll see if there's any
questions to you Thank You Wendell ready
rim good morning chair and everybody and
thank you for allowing me to speak today
boxford village the Parish Council and
myself remain totally opposed this
application which brings nothing of
benefit to our village we need proper
infrastructure in Boxford not more
highway nightmares just the facilitator
Carbunkle of a housing block and the
fire
end of the village at the moment much is
said about our infrastructure it's very
difficult to access shops pubs because
of our parking issues and highway safety
as was highlighted by the inspector this
application if built would make Ella
Street the same as Swan Street with
narrow pavements where they're widened
that wouldn't be enough room for the bus
to pull up and there is just not room
for two-way traffic parking and a foot
way at the top of Ellison Street it is a
total impossibility our own village
neighbourhood plan because well advance
can provide extra parking in the centre
of the village near the school also a
place for school extension and
designated nature and wildlife area up
to the bypass we do have the agreement
of their landowner there we just need
our planners to work with us not to sink
all the hard work of 50 volunteers on
this no well advance plan in a recent
appeal planning application zero to
three one six four forty dwellings
announced it was turned down by the
inspector and one of the major factors
was the local neighbourhood plan which
at that time was about as bounced as
ours is please work with us I think the
response from our strategic planners is
accurate and should be taken note of in
the first instance I think I should
highlight here we do not need a piece of
land to put the building on and there is
no building involved here it is a piece
of land which something that could be
built on at a later stage already
including a large Sports Pavilion in
Boxford on the playing field
the massive Scout up at the Spinney and
the guide centre the brilliant village
hall and also the church building
halfway up Swan Street we do not need a
fifth
I have massive concerns also regarding
the soakaway called suds this belongs to
somebody else now though it is on the
application land I do not think the site
the application proposed is correct we
have had flooding in this instance over
many many years and water goes out into
the houses at Brook hole road and into
the village and has flooded several
times but since this has been in place
it has saved the village from the former
planning problems it is totally in the
wrong place for these things to work you
must send water uphill and then it soaks
down through the passage of time having
sixty five houses of sixty four houses
sorry plumbed into this even if it was
four times the size it would never cope
it would make serious problems for the
village I also have massive concerns
regarding the school and the placements
my neighbours recently had a child
refused even though she's in catchment
and I think it can be said that pretty
much every child that lived on this new
application site would have to be bussed
with all the environmental issues and I
think that at the moment is a major
major consideration I would also
highlight the surgery which at the
moment due to shortage of doctors is not
having any consultations it merely been
used as a dispensary we hope in future
we will get it back but in is a definite
possibility in years to come that we
have no surgery facilities in Boxford at
all when considering can you please
consider the huge cost of busing young
students miles where from they live and
a massive environmental impact thank you
for listening and chair and committee
and I will be pleased to answer any
questions thank you so much thank you
very much Council
I don't know what that interruption was
but you managed to battle through
requires any of us it's quite load
that's it it wasn't from my phone chair
that's the mystery yeah okay yes it is
to me as well perhaps the officers would
tell us later anyway
members canceled Osborne you have a
question yes thank you mr. chairman and
yes I've been listening to the reasoning
for the highways issues that the road
down to Oxford and around there is
chock-a-block okay I just like to ask
what evidence perhaps has he of of as
the war men have got for this so-called
chock-a-block of traffic within within
that area please I think the main
concern Adrian is the junction there
there is various farms and the machinery
dealer up the top of Cox Hill and we've
had numerous occasions with lorries on
that pinch point at the corner we are
going for some new signage to try and
make things come through the village as
opposed from the Hadley end of the
village from the bypass but once again
the village was also so at the pinch
point from the church across to the
surgery the wall has been severely
damaged to many many occasions the
problem was booked with sorry Brinn are
you talking about the care yeah yeah so
quickly and down from there where the
proposed foot waves going the road is
not wide enough to facilitate all this
this will make the whole of Boxford the
access from both sides just single lane
traffic and nothing can pass and people
are constantly backing up to let one
thing through and this is affecting the
shops in the center of the village as
well because the clogging of traffic
kids nobody can leave a car the popper
and get a bit of paper it's hard to
access the butchers than trying to
answer the question I think
you pointed out that where the
bottleneck is just come back mr.
chairman yes councillors born can I can
I ask then if that is the case why
hasn't this been identified with Suffolk
County highways we Adrian we are always
on to Suffolk highways both on this
application and as you know on the
Goodland application it was a major
thing and it was the reason the
inspector turn down the 24 houses
because it's not safe he highlighted
pedestrian safety as a major issue the
fact you cannot walk down from that end
and this will then be the same if these
are built and canceled Aharon I will get
the officer when we're finished
questions to you to comment on that that
whose points that you've just raised
okay earlier I've got a question from
Ken Salome Melanie Barrett Chancellor
Barrett sorry
it's sticky with the yes
good morning brain and good morning
Melanie hi there um we've heard a bit
about some of the objections have been
around the congestion at Swan Street and
the accounts of how difficult it is to
negotiate up Swan Street which has many
parked cars and it's preferable to for
residents heading north to at various
and opens direction it's difficult to
understand how this affects this
application when the new building will
be built right on the bypass and they
would be a number of metres away from
joining a bypass Boxford is quite easy
quite lucky it has a bypass don't can't
you envisage that this will not increase
the congestion to Swansea because
there's a ready-made alternative that's
within
you know easy reach for for new there
any any houses that are built on sandy
sandy Hill I think the problem is
Melanie that motorists tend to follow
their noses if you're going to bury or
to Cambridge you won't go onto the
bypass and go via Hadley or even worse
you won't go down via Sudbury you will
cut through up SWANA Street towards
Lebanon and join the one three four and
go that way and that is what people tend
to do it will anyone going north or
Northwest will tend to go up Swan Street
and cut through the country roads it's
I'm afraid that's the way we're built
it's just a natural instinct thank you
the catchment area the report contains
information for is that this could
result in 16 primary age children
traveling by bus but there are currently
18 pupils attending boxford from the
stokke by Nayland primary school
catchment so they have got a school they
could attend but they choose to come to
Boxford no doubt because it's an
excellent school do you think that by
the time this this could be built out
within a couple of years there'll be a
natural allocation to residents from
Boxford rather than out of catchment and
that could resolve some of the parking
issues near to the school because best
parents will be dropping off by car I
think Melanie will work out a little bit
but the problem is where I live in
Abington and Newton Greene those already
70 houses either built and quite the
food some of the other catchment village
as well any take up from the active
catchment children gradually being eased
out of the school has already been taken
up and I know in this year's intake I
believe they're all local children who
applied and been allowed and there has
been a refusal on purely local children
and I don't think that it's going to
change I think any
additional children admitted to come to
Oxford school there will be a fight to
get in and some will be turned away as
they had this year and last year it's
just the school is popular but it's not
big enough and we can't expand it unless
we have infrastructure in a different
place to this which is well advanced to
cancel it Jameson Thank You Tara I bring
hi good morning
no surgeries currently closed and just
been uses the dispensary
so this right does that mean the
residents currently has good Headly for
and in which a sneak and I interrupt you
I'm sorry I can't hear you you're either
going to have to speak into the phone I
know I'm a bit depth but I'm not capped
in any of that get closer
thank you say the surgery is currently
closed and just being used as a
dispensary that is correct so does that
mean the residents of Oxford having to
go to Headley for the surgery for
medical appointments and doctors
consultation it's all been done out of
Hadley surgery at the moment there are
no consultations at all they the
providers of the surgery have said that
they wish it to remain a surgery and to
come back and we're working on that but
the problem is there's they just don't
have the staff the medical staff the
doctors to stop it
so sighting truck to brain so it's
purely down to throwing a far as it goes
staff it's lack of available doctor that
they don't need it Hadley and this
happened before um go over 19 chairman
Frank they just don't have enough
doctors to staff up thank you so this
development won't really have any effect
on there at all then really I mean it's
it's currently no doctors here this
won't make this development won't make
the metal
you'll still need to go to Headley they
will go to Hadley but hopefully if we
can get Botsford surgery back as a
consultant surgery if this was built
they would go there and ease the
pressure run Hadley which must be pretty
tremendous at the moment I would think
think thank you thanks thanks thank you
there's no other counselors wanting to
ask questions according to the chat box
so I'm going to assume then that there's
no more questions to the ward member so
we'll move on and thank you everybody
thank you and we'll go into debate just
before I open it I want to ask the
officers Jack wherever he can just
comment on who don't know who it was I
think it might have been canceled Aharon
but my apologies if it wasn't but the
ownership of the suds area was
questioned and I'm assuming he's talking
of that little bit that sort of go off
the of the plan into the back garden of
somebody's house if you can show that
picture on the map jack and just explain
that to us
thank you chair just bring up that image
again yeah I think you know that a
little bit yeah so in terms of the sides
you know jump through yeah they even say
it may the little red bit goes into a
green area this is station field right
that was previously approved you can see
that the red line for the application
extends across the boundary into this
application site right this is the
previous application
it was refused yep and you can see and
I've chosen to use this one because it's
it's a closer up it's a better image you
can see the outfall we've
the watercourse that this would link to
subject to filtration and flow control
mm-hmm the existing soap way that serves
station field is outlined here this
would be integrated along with the
attenuation basin procedurally there is
nothing for members to worry about the
correct certificates have been signed on
the application form so I'm more than
happy to to say that thank you now that
the too plentiful sir mark Russell yes
sorry sorry Cheerios just want to get
the microphone off I just want to
clarify a couple of points and then I'm
actually I've been asking Jack whether
he could just clarify a highways point
at the end of this so I've got three
short points the d1 use that we'd
discussed that the scheme does not
succeed or fall on that offering it sits
there as a as a thing it's seen as a
benefit by officers we've had a
discussion about whether it's needed or
not the scheme does not fall if that
were not supplied so that just must be
put out there as a point the second
point I wish to raise is about the
neighborhood plan this has been
mentioned once or twice now I was of the
view it had limited weight but I did
check with the neighborhood plan officer
mr. Bryant and he's telling me the
neighborhood plan the moment has no
weight at all it's just a designated
plan area so I would ask members to
recognize that the work is beginning but
as a document there is no white to be
attached to any neighborhood plan in in
boxford and the third point was just
about the buses I think we've talked
about it for some time for the school
kids it's a short-term problem perceived
as such and the offerings for seven
years whilst supposedly as it's being
claimed local children can take up the
places which currently are held by our
out of village people those are the
three points wish to raise chair and I
think Jack would like to just clarify
the difference between this and the Swan
Street appeal and then I do have a
question from Council of Busbee read the
soakaway so after Jack spoke oh then get
him to put that question to you to thank
you
Jack Thank You chair um
yes I've already sort of touched upon
the Swan Street appeal and I've
mentioned it earlier on and I also
mentioned it in the previous refusal and
certainly it is relevant however there
are stark contrasts in this proposal too
that I've mentioned it on paragraph 9.5
in the report and I will read it with a
bit of as stated the inspector concluded
in that appeal the stone the Swan Street
appeal that the scheme would cause
unacceptable highways impacts owing to
the narrow stretches of pedestrian are
way along Swan straight with
obstructions telegraph poles protruding
buildings and wheelie bins and a much
higher likelihood of pedestrian vehicle
collision given the amount of Park cars
in the locality I digress in terms of a
pinch point this site the site before
you today is a lot different to that
there is a 1.2 meter wide pedestrian
foot way leading into the centre of the
village which would enable safe and
sufficient access for pedestrians this
was not part of the reason for refusal
last time out and members didn't find
reason to exploit that further I'd like
to be clear on the drawing that is
hopefully viewable by all yes this is
set on a topographical survey
it is a thick stating point accurate
measured survey that would have been
laser measures inclusive of boundaries
and indeed the accurate widths at the
minute the proposal includes formalized
parking bays proposed bus stop along
with speed limit signage this would be
materializing through a section to 7/8
agreement
I don't really wish to elaborate further
must-make members aware that this is an
accurate drawing which your officers
have relied upon thank you thank you
thank you councillor Busby your question
read the soakaway and then I'll open up
debate afterwards yeah actually if he
whilst Jack's going back to that picture
of the soakaway just to pick up a point
that Mark mentioned there he referred to
the the problem with bussing kids out of
Boxford to an early primary school is
only short term or seven years is quite
a long term into in terms of a
children's education it would mean that
some children would may never ever go to
their local school seven years they
could be in an album have to have to
travel so I think short term is relative
but the question on the circa way the
owners of station field Suffolk housing
I think have they commented on the
proposals directly capsule of Osby yes
they've submitted a very light objection
which is with us and that states that
they haven't received correspondence to
do with the cycleway extension if you'd
like I think the crucial factor here is
procedural soundness can we as a local
planning authority determinist
application based on a whether the site
location is correct either land
ownership and see whether the correct
certificate has been served we've
checked this out and the land falls
within the applicants ownership and as
such they're well within their right to
explore the merging or indeed the uplift
of the soakaway that serves station
field this is largely civil in terms of
what we determine as an authority there
is nothing to be concerned with yeah
thank you so you're happy with that it's
it strange that the existing circa way
for station field was
permission to being somebody else's land
an order thought having gained that
permission they would therefore retain
control over it wouldn't not necess
sorry not necessarily no I think if you
make all the red line extends off into
the application site before us in terms
of what's proposed now and you can apply
for Planning Commission on anyone's land
providing use you correctly serve the
right certificate certificate saying be
in this instance you've got an
application which is accurate in terms
of what they proposed on the land might
have permission to apply on thank you
I've got Julie IP Taylor who's coming in
on this particular point so I'm gonna
take you next can you just explain who
you are please I know that remembers
Thank You chair I'm I'm I'm the
strategic housing team manager and I was
very involved with station field as the
ward member is is aware when that was
coming through the planning committee
process station field was the landowner
of station field before it was
transferred to Suffolk housing society
is the same land owner of this
application site before committee today
thank you that clears that point up
right Thank You members I'm now gonna
open it up for debate so I'll start with
councillor Aires and then if anybody
else wishes to speak perhaps you're just
happy in the chat box counsel Aires
transfer Aires hello can you hear me
can anybody hear me yes okay yes that
does go off the screen I've had that
problem thank you cancel my haze I'll
start with you
yes what I was wondering was it's a very
old Victorian school in boxford and if
they don't need this this building or
this dis facility I'm just sort of
pie-in-the-sky should they no not go to
new school oh there Jack don't forget
part of the application but did you want
to comment we've got what's in front of
us I think we have to determine what's
in front of us and realistically yeah I
won't go too far back into the school's
discussion but counsel do not object
they endorse this game in terms of the
delivery and provision of school places
I don't going to be a school comfort I'm
soon in this particular catchment and I
think they've mentioned that in their
comments until councillor McClaren Thank
You chair and I would like to just
reflect on what we've seen we've got an
application that is at the far end of
the village and the parish council
assured us that within their proposed
neighbourhood plan they had identified
smaller sites which presumably are in
the body of the village wouldn't those
developments creates a greater gridlock
and traffic problem within the village
centre I just thought that might be
useful thank you okay can you help Det
I don't know if you know where these
others are but I don't in terms of
highways and potential congestion you
could argue that congestion may be
generated from from from sites that's
that's apparent in any application
as to whether it's within the centre of
Oxford
I'll leave manage to arrive along
conclusion on that thank you
any other member wish --is to take up in
debate yes please
council about thank you chair a little
bit off the wall apologies for that
um could could there be a solution to
took the school places there's a nursery
on the site of the boxer school for the
under unjust age children there's a
community potential for community use on
on the site of Thea this development
that would free some space at the school
just just put it out there as a as an
option it's not for perhaps for
developer to have conversations with
them education suffered we can comment
on that I think it's part of a wider
discussion and closely I think this
scheme would potentially facilitate a
discussion of that nature the proposal
includes a d1 building and the variety
of uses that fall within that use class
and assets out on the use classes order
the stance taken by the County Council
is that they have a duty to provide
school places this remains a notice in
terms of the displacement there would be
a displacement but realistically that is
that is a short-term problem we still
have to provide places for schools of
school children so I'll leave that with
members to consider and debate Thank You
chair well done Melanie unlike some
creative thinking I'd like to
congratulate Katie on on their revised
plan I think they've taken on board a
lot of the problems with the first
and have created quite a nice
development however there's always a
however what concerns me is that the
support for this scheme it's not in the
existing development plan it's not in
the emerging JLP it's not in this
neighbourhood plan that's being
developed by Boxford it's not supported
by any policy it's not supported by the
PC so despite the fact that it looks
like a quality development without this
support the quandary really and I know
people will say ah well yes the you can
only give limited ways to the jail
because it's not finalized yet and you
can't only limited went to the
neighbourhood plan because that's not
fun not finalized yet as well actually
once the JLP has been signed off it's
out of date the fact that is emerging
means cities at its most current and
accurate and therefore probably ought to
carry more weight so the fact that it's
not in any of these plans either
existing or future plans that we've
identified our presume it wasn't they
might have come forward in the call for
sites but has been rejected I find it
difficult that we can support it however
good the development is Thank You
councillor Busby councillor Hinton Thank
You mr. chairman um yeah I got rather a
long list of points here that I've been
wading through all seated between more
and more papers in these reports and
than ever before but I've got concerns
in that the basic reasons for refusal
that were on page 14 of the report from
the that we previously highlighted have
been tinkered with but haven't actually
been addressed we've got one comment for
instance in in the report where it talks
about answers only part on page 14 only
partially
address the problems well if they're
only partially addressing the problems
and they're still just as valid as
reasons for refusal as originally the
school bus scenario is something that I
think most people would think is a
concern because primary school children
having to get on a bus and go to school
is not exactly an ideal situation
we heard join the joiner debate the an
object that the objector said that the
bus runs the service bus runs the hop
has five the last bus from Sudbury and I
know that the last bus to Hadley from
Ipswich is at five o'clock so anybody
who wants to use the bus to go to work
hasn't got an option we also see in the
report that he talks about access to the
work areas I'd like to know where they
are in in Boxford is somebody can tell
me that councillor Busby's just made the
point about no allocations paragraph
three point two four on page 27 talks
about diminished emphasis rather than it
being eradicated so watering down
reasons for refusal is not exactly a way
to make them approvable so that there
are numerous things on this which I
don't think that the revised application
has addressed this is an outline
application but if it is approved as an
outline application it establishes the
development potential for the site and
anything could come back then as a
reserved matters and we've only got to
see some some faith use the word but
jiggery-pokery in terms of five-year
land supplies to see our policies
sidelined in favor of the MPP F but even
the MPP F says that infrastructure and
sustainability should be important
there's a lot of emphasis on if people
use cars they should be using electric
cars which is great
but you still got a part the damn thing
somewhere you don't stack them up in the
air or stack them up on end they still
take up plate that space and as we've
heard from the local Member
parking in the middle of the village is
a real problem because it just stops
everything dead so I don't think that
anything has been put together here one
of the other major points that I would
just like to point out is that the
justification for this has still not
been established in terms of what should
be there it's supported by a local
housing needs assessment dated December
2019 this is on page 29 which provides
evidence of a local housing need through
secondary data what does that mean they
consulted with Eskimos at the North Pole
to find out whether or not they needed
houses in Suffolk it doesn't really sort
of tell us anything and then a bit
further on in the report it refers back
to the Suffolk housing needs survey of
2014 as being a valid document but it
wasn't valid when they produced it in
2014 because he'd only took a 5% sample
across Suffolk and didn't actually
pinpoint what the sample actually was in
terms of demographics so there was no
real evidence to say that the
information it produced was valid it was
the classic example of lies lies and
damn statistics you can prove anything
as long as you move the parameters so
there is nothing in this revised
application to endorse it to me as a
valid application that can be put
forward without having significant harm
upon Boxford and ultimately of course on
Baber district Thank You Chancellor
Hinton I have to say I can't agree
entirely with your comments because I
feel that there has been a lot of work
done by officers in this whatever
they've answered them satisfactory to
how you would like them answered I don't
know but I'm gonna ask Jack if he can
comment on any of and Mark Russell where
they can comment on any of the comments
you've made which might be helpful to us
and what Dave Busby was saying please
I'll go first chair I just have to go
back to the first principles of what to
consider that they have to repeat the
neighborhood plan has no weight at all
and the emerging JLP joint local plan
has limited way
so the first place we go to as per the
NPP F is the is the existing plan and we
are aware that cs2 on its own is not a a
policy we can use for a decision on its
own it's accepted it's outside of the
built-up area boundary so it does fail
policy cs2 but we can't refuse it for
that alone so we then go on to the
considerations under CS 11
these have been spelt out in Jack's
report obviously there won't be there
will be disagreements about the
interpretation of each limb of that
policy that's what this is all about but
RR starts is there's a cs2 failing and
an almost blanket success under the CS
11 considerations so that's where we go
to and we go to the NP PF and
sustainability so under those
considerations the scheme stands up and
we mustn't be swayed by the jail P or
the or the neighborhood plan because
these have firstly limited and secondly
no weight at all so we do have to
remember that and Donnell to Jack before
Jack I think I'll just take Julie Abbott
Taylor and she wants to clarify a point
for councillor Hinton and then I'll come
to Jack Thank You chair it was just
clarify the reference I think in the
case officers report about secondary
data
what what what the applicant has
provided is an analysis of housing needs
based on the Office of National
Statistics census data the strategic
housing market assessment report that so
there has not basically carried out a
direct housing needs survey that has
gone to every household in Boxford all
the wider planning cluster and the I
think in my consultation responses I did
make the point that the strategic
housing market assessment report that
the applicant has relied upon was the
previous one published in 2017 not the
revised one in 2019 thank you thank you
mr. chairman if I could just comment on
that and say well the census data says
nearly ten data is nearly ten years old
and the
National Statistics updates things every
year during which time it has said that
the growth of Baber is one of the lowest
in the eastern region with something
like 200 people a year being growth in
terms of people so on that basis we
would only need somewhere in the region
of 200 or maximum houses across the
whole of the district and yet we're
building that more than that a year
Jack Thank You chair and with that I
think it's prudent to highlight the
recent appeared in long Welford the
inspector was relatively clear in their
stance which is recovered by the century
of state and they concluded as I have in
power 3.44 of my report out of 53 of
their appeal decision even if there is a
local need and even if there is a
five-year housing land supply
government's objective is to
significantly boost and supply homes
that is abundantly clear and the wording
in that was that he considers that the
housing deliveries should carry
significant weight and that's that's
kind of tying in with what Mark has
already mentioned as well about CST
serious 11 and 16 yes there will be
tension with cs2 however we're stating
as officers that this scheme complies
fully with CS 11 which is your
development policy for court
insolent villages so only that we've
members to consider thank you I've got
canceled about Melanie Barrett thank you
um I I just want to add some some
comments just to to say we will have to
give be mindful of the office
assessments that they've just given us
and the weight that we must give to the
policies and that is you know he is
based on the most up-to-date assessment
current character across all judgments
inspectors views etc
this is a this is a core village
so it's sustainable it wouldn't be a
core village really if it wasn't
sustainable I don't think and you know
we know that it's got a good range of
services and a school yes I don't think
children should be bused to primary
schools but at the moment as we know 16
of those pupils are being taken by car
to the school that's not there
they're in their village at the moment
they're out of catchment now and so this
could address some of that
except ultimately it could take a few
years but I guess that is until you know
the out of the year sort of longest
longest stretch that would be needed I
think we do need to explore some some of
these options thank you councillor Busby
for your comment but there could be a
solution that we we need to apply as as
warned members that is part of our role
is to look beyond and look for those
solutions to to better residents live so
it's probably something that seriously
needs to be looked at the nursery
location and and potential for that to
be located on this this I wish doesn't
seem to it to extreme an option given
that the parish council don't really
want it just another village hall which
yes I can understand that they want it
to have perhaps have a meaningful for
use that could be a meaningful use that
would actually provide real benefit and
that is what we're trying to weigh up
how can we ensure that the the residents
benefit from this rather than you know
you know just have harm so it is really
difficult and important to weigh up some
of those elements and not ignore the
benefits when we're considering the at
the harm
thank you thank you
well members there's no one else down to
speak we've been debating a soy little
wild is there any new points anybody
wish to add and canceler Buzzbee yeah I
want to go take on this point I know
that Lee the plans are emerging and
therefore Nek a certain amount of weight
but like the officers to answer surely
this site was put forward as a site in
the core four sites
it was evaluated by Planning Policy and
the the jlpt as not being suitable
that's not emerging that is a fact so
how are they arguing that their view of
this site is stronger and more correct
than the people who were paid to
evaluate that scientists I think
handsome husband we were told that there
was no weight to this ployed
Jack can you help us out Thank You chair
and yeah as emphasized by mark that is
of limited weight I think we have to
consider the application on the basis of
today here and now and where we are in
terms of development plan policies and
the MPP F a local level and a national
level and the direction of travel in
terms of how government have set out the
con for the country to become developed
I think we have to respond to recent
appeal precedent mainly long Melford
it's relevant to the district certainly
but also wider areas and I think in
terms of our policies they have been
tested on numerous occasions as we well
know and there is nothing before us to
suggest that we should change from the
prevailing position set by inspectors
and some very senior inspectors and that
would mainly relate to the principle of
development highways position and also
the school's position
in this particular case so I can eyes
the development plan policy position and
the objection from planning policy
however the basis of those comments or
on plans which are of limited weight and
we cannot ignore that and that is the
position taken in on well fit thank you
well members there's no one wishing to
speak so it's just come back on
something else yes if we approve this
tent Allah Busby that is yep if we
approve this could I ask as a condition
that the public building is fitted with
superfast broadband so that it can
expand some of the potential uses I
think that's a very fair suggestion
counselor condition 33 I set out relates
to super slash ultra-fast broadband so
there's every chance that that could be
incorporated in future d1 building very
good point Ken slippers be canceled
Barrett thank you can I propose that we
move to approve this application so are
you proposing the officers
recommendations as set out in the papers
before us yes thank you and that point
that was just brought up by Dave Busby
as picked up in all that according to
the case officer do I have a seconder
right there's no one coming forward so I
will second the proposal so that we can
move forward so now it's been proposed
and seconded so you must know asked is
there any more debate that you wish to
go into only solid so I would they put
it the proposal it's been proposed by
Chancellor Barrett and seconded by
Councillor beer that we accept the offer
recommendation that is in the papers
before you members all those in favor I
will now ask the officer Rob to do a
roll call Thank You chair I see there's
something else coming can I request a
recorded vote
penciler barrett is that correct I was
just gonna say chair any member can ask
that their vote is but individually or
that you can ask they propose three
members can request that a recorded vote
is taken
I gave slightly incorrect advice last
time at the meeting because I was
looking at the council procedure rules
it's only three members not five so to
request a record for recorded vote air
thank you
right are you calling for a full record
of both of the committee and that's
right right so do I have a seconder for
sorry do I have three two other people
who wish to cancel not Osborn that's two
counselor as this three so we have we
will now have a recorded vote that be
recorded in the minutes is that correct
or up days correct chair yep thank you
now ask you to go through the roll call
for that thank you thank you very much
so counselor sue Aires a cruise
cancel Melanie Barrett for
councillor Peter beer for NASA David
Busby
regrettably before sorry Bryn do not
interrupt against Kelly Jamison against
cousin Mary McLaren for Kessler Adrienne
Osborne
well thank you sir
councillor Alison Owen for cats the
Steven plum
Tesla plumb pencil aplomb
engaged thank you you get that yes thank
you counselor
yes we've got that good so that motion
is carried
chair by 7 2 3 glad you confirm my legal
the legal officer here is confirming
that is carrot 7 those 2 3
thank you very much then I accept that
this has been approved and we will now
move on to the next one but to give
everyone a counter break can we take
about 6 minutes off tom be back by 11:30
please mr. chairman
yeah can I can I just express my thanks
to you
Yeah right Thank You chair so I'll
conduct the roll call for this second
item of the day yep so we have could you
if you could please answer it with
present all good morning council Suez
good morning present Council Melanie
Barrett present council appear present
councillor Busby still here counselor
John Hinton still here council early
Jameson new a prison counselor Mary
McLaren present Kessler Adrienne Osborn
present counselor Alison Owen listen and
Cal Sally Parker
Casa Parker joined us
let him into the meeting now so we're
just to go down the list of and then
we'll come back to that point and I'll
raise the point in a moment so
councillor plum resident counselor Clive
Alfie present councillor Margaret Mabry
yes present and I'll just go through as
well chair the public speakers to make
sure we have everyone so mr. Robin
Morley just to confirm you're still here
present Thank You mr. Mark Webster mr.
Webster we can pet
mr. Dave King prison thank you and then
as we've said we've checked the ward
members so I will just see with mr.
Webster one person waiting in Lobby
that's mr. Webster again so that's just
so ok mr. Webster you there thank you so
we don't need to point out cancel apart
if he's joined us Mandy if you could
just give him a ring please - just check
those not he's showing here but not here
at the same time if that makes sense
thank you but with technology sometimes
it doesn't just elaborate on the point
of councillor Parker joining as yeah so
after discussing with the monitoring
officer and legal adviser councillor
Parker he's able to join the meeting
despite giving his apologies because he
does not have a substitute for the
meeting and will not have heard any of
the discussion or any of the item that
we will now be going into which is DC
1904 7 5 5 it's not under the rules
regarding regulatory meetings as long as
the members heard the start of an item
doesn't preclude them from taking part
as far as they hear the whole of the
item after remain present throughout now
penciler Lee Parker are you present I
will have to start this meeting very
soon that pencil a Parker can you I
[Music]
believe my colleague Mandy Smith is
trying to contact him at the moment yes
if we give it just a couple more minutes
and then it will be your discretion if
that's acceptable okay counselor Parker
should be in the meeting now okay well
done Mandy chancellor Parker can you
hear us we cannot hear you
it's Mandy here I've just spoken to
councillor Parker and he said that he
was on another call and would be joining
us shortly so I told him that we're
waiting for him so I'm hoping that he's
going to reconnect call as soon as
possible could I just ask and everyone
seemed oh my screen share yes that's
that there lend a tray of clowns free
sing quickly thank you yes thank you
it's Margaret Mary thank you good I'm
going to have to start the meeting
I'm very sorry canceled early Parker are
you able to acknowledge that you're in
the meeting no I'm so sorry we will now
start the meeting at 9:42 according to
the clock on this computer place our
offices Samantha summers would you like
to introduce this okay thank you very
much chair and members of from page 51
of your agenda this application seeks
outline planning permission for the
erection of 28 dwellings and the
repositioning of three dwellings that
already have planning permission today
members will be considering the number
of dwellings on the site and the access
point only all other matters are
reserved the application site is located
on the great on great green in Koch
field to the north of the plow in fleece
public house which is here there is
mature tree about to the northern
boundary just here which protects views
from the wider landscape jukes meadow
shares a boundary to the east
the public houses to the south of the
plot and the access point is from very
Road the application site is on the edge
of the village to planning permissions
have been granted near to the site ten
dwellings have been granted just here
and a further five dwellings have been
allowed on appeal in this section he the
site is outside of the built-up area
boundary of cork field I which is
classed as a hinterland village the
built-up area boundary is shown by the
brown line the site is also outside of
the proposed settlement boundary in the
emerging joint local plan cork a great
green of cog field has actually being
downgraded in that plan from a
hinterland village to a hamlet however
that document is given limited weight at
this stage because of its early stage
the policy team had raised an objection
and that full objection is actually in
your table papers so that you can see
that there are listed buildings around
great green the nearest one is this one
here which it is old house farm there
are also several other listed buildings
just to the south which include the
thatched cottage and forged cottage
heritage team have identified listens to
potential harm to the setting of the
designated heritage assets and also
includes the fitting of the public house
which is considered to be a non
designated heritage asset however your
officers feel that the setting of the
heritage assets has already been eroded
by this development of joobs meadow and
also the five dwellings that were
allowed on appeal
this shows the layout of the ten
dwellings that already have planning
permission and they are currently under
construction the access point to the
development that you're seeing today
would be via this access and would come
through here so the application also
includes a repositioning of these three
dwellings to allow for the access point
into this real piece of land just here
the repositioning of those three
dwellings does also form part of this
application this shows the layout of the
five dwellings with the public house
located just here our site is just here
and as you can see the five dwellings
would wrap around the public house the
appeal statement for those five
dwellings is actually also in your table
papers just so that you can see the
context of why they were allowed this
shows the access point with Barry Road
just here and the repositioning of the
three dwellings to allow access through
the application site it would need to
break three the scheme has not raised
any objections with Suffolk County
Council highways they have requested
that a financial contribution of
eighteen thousand and sixty pounds is to
be secured by section 106 agreement and
that would go towards improvements to
the footpaths in great green this
application was received in October last
year following the parish council
meeting which the applicant attended
revisions were made to the indicative
layout plan the original scheme was good
for thirty-one dwellings with public
open space talked at the back of the
site just here in the northern section
of the site and a thin landscaping belt
was
opposed between the existing dwellings
of Jukes Nadeau and the new development
covering negotiations with both your
offices and the parish council to revise
schemes have come forward this is the
scheme the members are considering today
the layout is considered to be
acceptable with the number of dwellings
reduced from 31 to 28 a wider
landscaping bow to the eastern boundary
has been incorporated and the public
space has been moved centrally within
the site a third path is proposed to
think this public open space just here
with great green this is a welcome
addition to both the residents and
existing residents of the village and
from a security point of view having the
public open space in this central area
with all the houses overlooking is much
more beneficial for children using it as
a play area the applicant has also
listened to the parish council about
including bungalows on the site and four
have been arranged
among the sensitive boundary with jukes
meadow St the other three dwellings
along that boundary are one and a half
story which will help mitigate against
any overlooking and overshadowing of the
properties that are there already a lot
of work and negotiation has gone into
the revised layout and although there is
an outline although this is an antlion
application with only the number of
dwellings and access to be assessed
today a condition that this layout shall
be used as the basis for a reserved
matters application is recommended if
members are minded to approve the
application a total of 11 affordable
units are to be provided on the site and
in summary at this
five two-bedroom dwellings thirteen
three-bedroom dwellings and ten
four-bedroom and wailings proposed and
that includes the four bungalows this
mix of housing is considered to be
acceptable with the parish council and
your offices and a condition to secure
the mix of housing on-site is also
recommended should members go forward
with a recommendation of approval the
application site is outside of the
built-up area boundary however it is
considered to be well related to
services and amenities within the
village that the site is just here and
great Green offers a public house the
flower place which is marked here
although there's no made of footpath on
great green there is space for
pedestrians to walk across the grass
area and to avoid vehicles there is a
footpath link along Chapel Road and Hal
lane to the other facilities in the
village and that would include the post
office stores the village hall the
primary school and some Peters change
the development is considered to help
secure the future of the primary school
as it is actually a undersubscribed at
the moment moving on to some photographs
of the area this shows great green from
trap or Road and the start of the
pavement which links great green edge to
the facilities within how Elaine this is
looking from great green along the road
towards how Lane and you can see the
made-up third party this is the public
house with the sight of the five
dwellings that were allowed on appeal
that would wrap around the public house
this is the entrance to Jukes meadow and
these are the houses that share the
boundary with the application site in
juice tomato bungalows are proposed
along this section here and one and a
half story dwellings further along this
section this shows the site of the
proposed pedestrian link just here and
that will link the open green space
within the site to this larger area of
green space of great green the public
house can be seen just hey this is great
green looking across agree into the
public house mature trees around the
green are a feature of this area of coke
field this shows the entrance just here
and the hoarding that is up currently
along Barry Road of the Tim dwellings
that are currently under construction
the access would come through here into
this site to the right which is a large
area much larger area for the 28
railings
this shows the mature tree belt that
runs along that northern boundary and
screams the development from the wider
landscape again just looking a bit
further north towards the tree belt and
the wider landscape this is going back
to the back of the public house where
the five dwellings are proposed you can
just see the blue marker posts which
show the individual plots of those five
dwellings you can see the houses in
Dukes meadow just beyond here the site
the application site that you're looking
at today is just beyond this boundary
this is the access point from there
erode looking into the site with the
tree belt on the left hand side there
this is looking towards great green from
the access point and this is looking in
the other direction along Barry Road
looking into the site a bit more in
detail unfortunately I can go onto the
site because of social distancing and
all of the workmen were actually on the
site at the time so these are distant
views across the application site you
can clearly see this tree about here and
the properties within duke's meadow just
there just a little bit of a zoomed in
shot of those dwellings this is where
the bungalows would be along this area
here and then further along would be the
one and a half story dwellings this is
the tree belt taken from very Road as it
as you can see from the wider landscape
you can't actually see into the site at
all is completely screened the scheme is
not completely equal to C compliant in
that there is no proven justifiable need
for the number of dwellings proposed
David does have a Bible and supply
however there is a high percentage of
smaller homes proposed which includes
some bungalows and eleven affordable
dwellings the applicant has worked
proactively from pre-op stage until now
on the number and type of dwellings on
site and has produced a layout that
incorporates a centrally located open
space although cork field is a
hinterland village it has a lot to offer
residents in terms of facilities which
include the primary school which is
within a safe walking distance from the
application site the less than
substantial harm identified by the
heritage team on the setting of the
heritage assets is considered to be our
weighed by the public benefits that the
scheme offers which include the other 11
for affordable dwellings the public open
space 18,000 and sixty pounds towards
improvements to footpaths and future
students to support the primary school
therefore this application is
recommended for approval with positions
is set out on page 75 of Europe thank
you very much for that Samantha right
members is there any questions I've
gotten Melanie Barrett
councillor Barrett I think thank you I
think Mike yes was much earlier actually
but I do just have a very quick question
we've got it on the screen at the moment
the slide 30 what are the blue blobs
okay any other questions no just please
mr. chairman sorry yeah okay in mind how
slow the notice board is just a quick
one yeah the proposal for affordable
housing shows summers shared ownership
could be clarify are we talking about
shared ownership or are we we're all
talking about rent to buy because we
seem to have different terminologies
depending on which officer has written
the report right I'm at this strip the
strategic housing team has specified
shared ownership on this scheme okay and
what is the difference between shared
ownership and rent to buy um to be
perfectly honest I don't know the answer
to that I'm not sure whether Mark
Russell would know the answer to that
question my understanding is it relates
to equity rent to buy you pay rent and
pay off for a mortgage and become the
owner
whereas shared equity as she had
ownership you would own let's say 50% of
it so when you sell it on you get 50% of
the equity and at the RSL gets the rest
of
any other points of clarification no
okay we'll move on we now go to the
public speakers we have the parish
council representative mr. Robin Morley
to speak you have three minutes in which
to address the committee and at the end
of that house there's any questions for
you when you're ready sir you may start
thank you and good morning good man the
parish council were cautious with the
very initial sight proposals although
through useful dialogue with the
developer
these are significantly involved
apprehensions do remain that the
application is only for outline with all
matters being reserved and any final
outcome may be somewhat different and
unacceptable copperfield has seen
substantive development in recent times
not wholly meeting the desires of the
parish council or residents and not
necessarily contributing to the
sustainability of the village the number
of facilities Menominee's continues to
dwindle
for example closure of the garage
reduction in bus services they demise at
the restaurant with those remaining
assets no doubt under pressure so we
have encouraged the type of newt
Wellings
that go towards mitigating this decline
and broaden the demographic this was the
view communicated with inabilities own
housing development survey the parish
council has always supported local
affordable and diverse home provision
and the type and mix of homes offered
with two three and four bed houses
chalets and bungalows together with the
requisite affordable contribution does
give a comprehensive opportunities for a
wide range of families couples
individuals and elder residents we
believe the development if executed
correctly does offer overall benefit to
the village it is essential however that
those impacted most directly are not
burdened
comments give me previous consultation
responses do need to be addressed one
further diversity improvement layout of
property types may be achievable in the
council support this is reading housing
team comments on this
matter to the concerns voiced by the
baby at mid Suffolk District Council
Harris's team are addressed and
incorporated in any reserved matters
application in terms of materials and
aesthetics three additional enhancement
to the boundary abutting digs meadow for
the existing tree buffer to the north of
the site must be maintained and
preserved under covenant and the
development does not extend beyond this
five the develop engages with the
adjacent residents whilst agreed the
landscaping matters in detail in order
to implement a sympathetic buffer to
these properties to lessen the impact of
development
finally six the parish counts will not
be available to any of the side plots
being self-build and this would detract
the baby with Suffolk district action in
indirectly the parish council receiving
cell funding
please note under consultation summary
relating to the Parish Council we feel
this is an accurate reflection of our
discussions and thoughts on this
application and subject to meeting
necessary planning criteria the Parish
Council does supports application also
we would support part four of the
presentation points 12 0 to 12 9 and the
inclusion of conditions outlined at the
end of the document good I just thank
you for the opportunity to speak thank
you very much well Thailand numbers
start with PES letters have you any
questions to the public speaker for the
parish council no thank you to anybody
else no thank you
we'll move on then I will know asked
objector mr. Mark Webster to speak you
sir have three minutes also to address
the committee and then I'll say there's
any questions at the end of that when
you're ready mr. Webster you can start
thank you and good morning
I objected the proposed development on
three grounds firstly the cumulative
impacts a material consideration in CS
11 and a concern that was
in several of the 16 objections lodged
if permission is granted a total of 73
new dwellings will have been approved in
the great green area including 15 all
immediately adjacent sites since 2017
this would represent a huge 56% increase
in dwellings since the start of the core
strategy period the report to committee
states that the scheme delivers an
attractive townscape quality a phrase
which highlights it's unacceptable scale
and style for a countryside setting this
scheme which has already been marketed
as coming soon on the developers website
is again outside of the built-up area
boundary and significant harm would
result to the landscape and character of
the area which is categorized as a
hamlet in the emerging plan you should
be noted that the woodland tree built
will be in the ownership of the
applicant secondly the site is not in a
sustainable location from a transport
perspective there is one bus a week from
the Great Green Bus stop providing a
two-hour mid-morning visit to berry on
Wednesdays and there are no plans for an
increase in this service the village
school is one point four miles away
there are two sections of the route that
not have a roadside footpath one in hay
lane that is particularly hazardous no
children of five to 11 years are likely
to walk to school in summer let alone in
winter residents would therefore be
entirely dependent upon car transport to
access nearly all service and employment
locations the proposal does not
therefore meet this a s15 sustainability
criteria of minimizing travel by car the
proposed footpath to the green is
usually continuously flooded in winter
it should be noted thirdly the conch
field village housing needs with 107
permissions already in the pipeline this
proposal would over provide between 20
and 56th Wellings based on officers
reasonable estimates of village housing
needs up to 2030 one existing
permissions were already substantially
utilized the school's capacity whilst
ensuring necessary spaces are available
for its wider catchment area
furthermore the affordable housing needs
of Caufield residents of which there are
nine on the favor waiting list will be
more than fully met by the 18 new
affordable homes being constructed in
the sustainably located Mackenzie place
development in the village
finally I withdraw members attention to
the objection of the council's own
strategic planning policy and
infrastructure officers who comment that
the application is a major development
proposal in a small rural settlement and
that it is not considered to conform to
national and global planning policy due
to its remoteness and limited
accessibility is considered
unsustainable and consequently harmful
thank you for the opportunity to speak
thank you very much mr. Webster members
I'll start with Suez any questions Thank
You chair no okay nobody else No thank
you very much we'll move on I would now
ask the agent to speak mr. Dave King you
also have three minutes in which to
address the committee and I'll service
any questions at the end of it thank you
Thank You Jay good afternoon chairman
and members my name is David King and I
am the scheme architecture consultant an
agent for the applicant this application
proposes the erection of up to 28 new
dwellings on land on the western edge of
great greening cop field and includes
the repositioning of three dwellings
already approved on line to the south to
enable access to be created the
application started life as a proposal
for 31 new dwellings plus rearrangement
of three approved ones however in
response to concerns of the parish
council and local residents the density
of the object evelopment has been
reduced and units deleted the
arrangement of the development has also
been amended to place the public open
space at its center and to show lower
dwellings are puting existing houses the
mix of homes has been also been amended
following discussions with your offices
and the parish
council members will be familiar with
planning policies and circumstances
where permission may be granted for new
housing outside villages the offices
report carefully considers the benefits
of the development in light of the
planning policies I do not want to
propose to repeat that balance and
exercise but instead wish to commend the
report to the committee and to thank the
case officer for her diligence I would
like to repeat from the offices report
the benefits of the scam market housing
affordable homes public open space and
additional students for the primary
school that's protecting its future the
unit mix will attract younger people and
families to the village which will help
housing churn and provide economic
benefits through the use of local
services and facilities
I appreciate that there have been
objections to the scheme including from
some neighbors to the east the applicant
again myself have tried to minimize the
impact of the new homes on the amenities
of neighbors and have attended to
meetings with the parish council and
amended the indicative drawings five
times we have also in the eyes with your
planning case officer and adjusted the
layout to address responses from council
chase I understand that the committee
has a difficult job to balance the
efforts of development on individuals
whilst ensuring that the needs of the
District Council as a whole are met
through new development the applicant
and myself had tried to address all of
the concerns from neighbors but I do
understand that is impossible to satisfy
everyone in every case I hope that the
committee will recognize the benefits of
the application see the lack of material
harm and he's willing to grant planning
permission today I would like to thank
your planning staff and the parish
council for their assistance and thank
you for giving me the opportunity to
speak to the committee today thank you
thank you very much well-timed I just
have one question for you the parish
council did state that they didn't want
to say any self-build
it's likely to happen because I know
that is something that the district
council does support but um what's your
view on that
no I can't confirm there will be no
self-build
Thank You members is there any other
questions you wish to ask the applicant
mr. Dave King no okay thank you very
much thank you and kill right no go to
the ward member just before I do that
can I just ask the officers and I think
it was the objector said that and I
think we had this explained tours in the
previous application something very
similar that our officers say this does
not comply with CS 15 Samantha can you
pick this up or mark I don't know which
one want to because we did a similar
question in the previous one so we don't
know in great detail I think actually
the response from our policy team goes
into the MPP F also and they
particularly quoted paragraph 79 which
talks about houses in the countryside in
response they have actually said that
they believe that this is a remote site
as described in the MPP F this is not a
remote site it is well connected to the
village it abuts the settlement boundary
and in that general sense of remoteness
it's not thank you thank you
right to the word or the alphabetical
order was kind to look close Harvey you
said five minutes in which to address
committee and I'll serve as any
questions for you at the end of it
chairman I'm happy to go first but I do
normally afford capsular Mabry the
courtesy of going first if she wants
well it's entirely up to you that when I
last councilor made very whether she'd
rather go first
I'm happy to ask you to go first thank
you right okay can everybody hear me
then you're okay yes we can all hear you
well I won't I won't keep you for very
long firstly I would say something by um
by way of
background and a little bit of this has
sort of been touched on already in Cocke
field there have already been approvals
that will generate over a million pounds
in SIL contributions that's nearly 10%
of Beiber's total and when you consider
that we started charging SIL some four
years ago it gives you an idea of what's
been approved recently in the village
this growth had followed Hockfield
parish councils housing survey which has
been referred to which identified a
level of growth that they felt the
village could accommodate and which
would help to sustain the community and
protect and support its facilities that
growth was identified at between fifty
and a hundred new dwellings this
application would bring the number of
new dwellings approved well over a
hundred and a likely population increase
of over two hundred and fifty people in
2011 the population of kok field was 868
so we're talking about a population
growth of around 30% there are those in
the village who say this is enough or
more than enough and earlier on you
heard from mr. Webster he's a bright
intelligent and articulate man he's also
on the parish council although he
removed himself from the parish council
debates on this because of his interest
so he articulated this point that people
are saying this is enough or more than
enough but [ __ ] field is a very large
village geographically with a number of
separate settlements and is likely to be
able to accommodate this level of growth
so long as it's not all centered on one
settlement turning to the application
before you this morning it is on the
edge of great green which is a focal
point for recreation activities in the
village and the largest of the
settlements in the parish objections
have mainly come from residents of Dukes
meadow which include mr. Webster earlier
on and that's immediately to the east of
the site and from residents in the
neighboring village of Bradfield
to the north the objectives from sheep's
meadow are not simply saying not in my
backyard and as you heard from what mr.
Webster said they've put together a
structured response which addresses
policies in our local plan and the MPP F
and they've also considered heritage and
highways issues the objectives from
Bradfield Sinclair a concern that the
development would generate additional
traffic along the roads through their
village with regard to highways of
course Suffolk County Council of always
have also responded with applications
such as this any identified hard must be
balanced against the public benefits and
I know you've already been through this
debate once this morning this was also
recognized by the parish council in
their lengthy deliberations and
engagement with the applicant I do
recognize that you could arrive at valid
reasons for refusal but my view is that
the revised application in front of you
today is acceptable in that the benefit
outweighs the harm that reasoning is
covered by the case officer in the
report at part four
this was highlighted to you by the
Parish Council as well that's paragraphs
twelve to twelve point nine I support
the recommendation for approval along
with the comprehensive list of
conditions and I'd like to thank
Samantha Somers for her work to ensure
those conditions go some way to address
the concerns expressed during the
consultation stages I would only ask you
and her to consider one additional
condition and that relates to the tree
belt to the north I understand that it's
not in the Red Line site but it is
within the blue line so it could be
included in conditions at this stage
aware that otherwise it might well be
included in the landscape scheme that
reserve matters but I think wait till
Samantha says but I think it can be
included at this stage and if it can I
would ask you to consider the additional
condition to protect protect the the
tree belt
that's it chairman and thank you for the
opportunity to speak thank you thank you
very much Ken salafi I will ask the
member if she can answer that question
because that might just be useful to
members to know before I go for question
Samantha can do quickly answer that
question for us it's certainly the
treebank can be written by condition if
members are so wish it to be this is an
outlying Commission so it could also we
could also be looking at that under the
landscaping section of a reserve matters
but to protect it fully it would need to
be done by condition right so if we
reminder to improve what's in front of
us we'll need to add that as an extra
conditions that correct that's correct
thank you very much just reminders
appropriate times if we get to that
stage Thank You members have you any
questions to the ward member claraklaver
fee counselor Jamison thanks chair
afternoon clover you say the Copperfield
has had lots of development and
computing that over a million paranthas
see oh is that right well it hasn't
actually contributed a million pounds
but well the approvals in Cocke field
are likely to generate that's the
existing approvals are likely to
generate a total SIL contribution of
just over a million pounds that's not
including this scheme and the the
overall SIL contributions as a result of
approvals for the whole of Baber I think
is it about eleven
I think about eleven million so it's
it's nearly ten percent of all of bocas
contributions will actually be coming
from Hockfield development offices
report on six and 3.23
he says the cop field has been left
behind with growth and is needs to be
leveled up long list of each country
which is true that's on page 62 66 63.23
yeah I didn't write that obviously so
better to ask the author which is I'll
let you pick that up when we get into
debate concerns
okay okay any other questions from
numbers no well just before I go to the
southern member Samantha can you
possibly pick that point out for
councillor Jameson two three okay thank
you
Caulfield is at one of the many villages
that we've seen recently that probably
hasn't had very much growth historically
for some years I think when baby lost
its five years and supply these smaller
villages did get quite an influx of
applications which were considered to be
acceptable at the time because we needed
the housing supply so everything's come
all at once for the village which I
think has been a bit of a shock that the
village itself and Kelton Thank You
Chancellor
the second board member councillor
Margaret maybe you have 30 minutes in
which to address the committee and I'll
service any questions at the end of it
when you're ready
thank you very much mr. chairman I
apologize to everyone at the beginning
if you hear some background noise it's a
neighbor doing some work I this planning
application in my opinion has been and
is a controversial one and I will
explain why that's not me originally was
classed as an infield site and I found
this quite difficult to appreciate
I absolutely admit that after this the
appeal site went through which could be
classed as an infill site however there
is a natural line of settlement and this
site sits outside it it is outside the
built-up area boundary which the officer
has agreed the village has taken a lot
of development including providing a
substantial amount of affordable which
the
should be proud of but also there is the
question of asking why the village is
being targeted the village is actually
much closer to Mary's and Edmunds and
therefore closer to West Suffolk Council
than to Baber District Council my fear
is that the development here the benefit
will be geared more towards that town
rather than our district the impact upon
the established Dukes meadow which
enjoys a quiet and reflective state
status within the village will be
immense I absolutely agree that the
applicant has tried to address this but
I still feel that more could be done the
natural area towards the north of the
site has been identified as needing
protection and there are concerns that
this natural area will be impacted upon
with such a development as this
I also query the play area within the
center I was one who stated that any
open area should be in the center of the
development make sure that everything
was being and happening correctly ie
that there was no anti-social behavior
however it must be remembered that the
play area will be it be the residents
who are responsible for maintaining this
and that it will come as usual under a
management scheme and I don't know if
everyone realizes this the developer
himself also has concerns on the
viability of the site as I heard when
attending various parish council
meetings this also gives me cause for
concern my concern is that in our
current situation of unprecedented
nature where commodities are in short
supply and prices have
increased it could be suggested that
this fight will become even more
unviable of course the developer will
have three years in which to build out
but I do have severe concerns that the
true nature in financial terms of the
site has not been investigated I'm still
here carry on yes we're listening
so II need some water I mean a enclosed
room
I have other comments to make I commend
to the Parish Council on their
generosity towards the developer and the
agent I also comment on their restraint
towards comments made by the same at
tooth parish councils which I was
present at I say this as in my opinion
the attitude from both the developer and
the agent was challenging to say the
least I feel this is the time to stake
freely that the developer and the agent
need to modify their approach and learn
to work with rather than against
residents in any area that they set
their future sights upon we have heard
from mr. King this morning however mr.
King was not present at these parish
council meetings I would like to end by
saying the way to a successful
relationship in any matter is by
respectful communication I am NOT
I feel counselor Maybury your time is up
Thank You mr. chairman Thank You members
you heard the comments there perhaps
don't pay too much attention to comments
regarding different people involved in
all this that may be hearsay or not but
the rest of it I'd like to ask the
question to you counselor maybe
ability you touched on can you just
sorta it's a question I should put to
the officers in a moment but I don't
know what the question is that I need to
put to them you are saying quite a bit
about viability do you have any facts or
do you know that there's problems or
what do I need to ask the officers I do
not have any answers it was just that
the developer at the parish council
meetings was quite firm that the
viability of the site was was difficult
it was a concern a huge concern yes okay
that's that's fine that I know what I
should ask officers members is there any
questions anybody wish to ask no no
thank you very much before I'll go to
debate Samantha or mark can you just
remind us about fire bility whether
there is a concern here that we need to
be involved concerned about Thank You
chair Sam may have some specific points
to make about this specific case B in
general we're dealing with an
application as presented to us we are
recommending approval on the basis of
what's being offered were the applicant
to say later and it's not viable we'd
have to look at it again of course and
it may be that counted against the
scheme and they didn't get a different
permission but we're looking at what's
in front of us now thank you very much
that was my fear none of the matter
right members we're now open to general
debate I'll start with Sue Ayers and
then if anybody else wishes to come in
perhaps they'll go in the chat box
cancer areas is there anything you want
to say I just want to say that I like
the way that the developers worked with
the parish council and this sort of
collaborative approach are really
impressed with that yep thank you
any other comments members
No could I could I just say I'm a
Barrett thank you I was going to comment
about the the cumulative that the
comments about cumulative and the recent
approvals that the seem you know quite
can quite substantial yeah but but I
think that you do have to look at that
in context of where we're you know has
the be in any development for the last
you know significant period and and it
is what we see it open fringes is the
the the substantial approvals and
developments there and this does balance
that out a bit and that should should
perhaps provide some comfort to
residents to think that this this we
could we can't we can't have development
solely in the open areas it must be
shared out but I haven't I haven't
formulated any further points at the
moment thank you any other members any
comments no one well I'll just asked the
offices can you just elaborate that if
we were minded to do down the road of
approval what this additional condition
that cancer our fee highlighted to what
we would actually need whether members
would want to support that if you can
give us a bit of detail in at please I
think we would probably go along the
lines that the trees within that tree
belt to the north here that they are to
be retained and not to be felled but
perhaps not good he might be able to
give you a bit more on the actual
wording of that condition right well
I'll leave the council our feet to think
about that and our asked in a bit later
in in that particular incident if we get
to that stage councillor Hinton
well Thank You mr. chairman
yeah just a couple of quick points
really firstly the comment on what
councillor Alfie was saying about sill
payments yes all the development that is
being proposed and approved in Cocke
field is scheduled to supply a
considerable amount of to this the silk
off of her baby
but I seem to remember on a couple of
the applications when the sums were
actually added up the actual
developments wouldn't produce enough SIL
income to cover the requests from the
County Council in particular for income
to all demands on the sill pot to cover
education etc so we have to be a little
bit careful about total income received
and total liabilities that it's actually
going to be put against and the second
point I'd just like to make is what
counsel about was saying was is
perfectly acceptable yes but what we
have to remember is that in the last
couple of councils even the development
within Baber has been tilted sixty
percent into the villages forty percent
towards the urban areas so the villages
have been taking a considerable chunk of
the development across the district okay
thank you
Breen and where I am on the window
numbers any other comments no right no
one's coming forward
well members in the absence of anything
come and fall from anybody then I'm
going to move the officers
recommendation from the chair as no one
else is saying anything or doing
anything so I would like to move the
officers recommendation for outlying
plan miss chair sorry chair I think
you've got delay there councillor
Barrett has already posted she's
proposing oh right I will stop well
though I'll carry on now I've done it
pointless and I will
pose that we grant outline plan
permission with conditions and we would
add on an extra condition that counselor
our fee has eluded to counselor Barrett
you wish to second this I see would you
like to make that yes I would like to
second that and and endorse the
condition yeah okay
I'm gonna ask the officer what she needs
to know from counselor our fee and
hopefully he's still listening and I'll
then asked him just to give us a bit of
clarification on it okay it was actually
Mark Russell that I thought would be
helpful in actually producing the word
yeah I think the safest route would be
what we probably need I don't know if
Sam could explain is there already a
detailed drawing showing the individual
specimens of the trees and everything
there is is there I don't believe so
what you would normally do is have a
condition saying only those trees to be
removed shall be removed I mean there's
no propose to remove any but some of
those trees will be poor specimens no
point trying to save something that's
dead or half dead or fallen day one
common thing yeah a condition with two
limbs or two different conditions one
would be a tree survey and this Andy
second would be compliance with the
findings off the tree survey happy with
that counselor Barrett yes that seems
seems fine yep good is there any
comments anybody want to put now before
I put this motion forward no okay
nothing's coming up and I am looking
right then it's been opposed by a pencil
a beer and seconded by Councillor
Barrett that we accept the officers
recommendation to grant outline planning
permission with conditions and the
additional one as laid out in your
papers
I will now asked Rob to do the roll call
thank you Jim
so if you could please respond with four
against or abstain counselor suit airs
for four just a Peter beer poor house
that David Busby for cancer John Hinton
abstain get Sally Jamison McLaren for
cattle agent Osbourne for Alison Owen
Paul counselor Steven plum or wait
Thank You chair that is carried by nine
votes none against him one abstention
the legal officer agrees that is indeed
the nine points in favor one abstention
and declare that that is approved and
permission I think we've got to the end
of the agenda members thank you very
much thank you for all those who
participated this morning and hopefully
we'll soon get back to having our
meetings in endeavor house but in the
meantime we will have to continue to do
it this way thank you very much and
goodbye to all thank you
[Music]